right after school I just like shiny
like lens of a gym so I can climb it
[Music]
it's a dangerous sport but only think
that I'm afraid of is not being able to
get to those awesome
[Music]
exclaiming I don't think that it really
matters it's how big you are if you're
smaller you can hold on longer and your
hands might be small ways so you can fit
more fingers on hold I started climbing
in central Pike when I was six years old
now I don't think I can like live
without it when very close to the top of
the climber trying to do conforms
usually feel like they're going to
explode and they're going to like first
open and you feel like you have to let
go but it's climbing you just can't let
go I think that climbing is it's
obviously a sport it's also like a dance
it sort of has to be able to like slow
up the wall and come up with your own
technique suggest to accomplish I think
people shock if I do something that they
can't do is something because I'm still
really young and I'm a girl so like
doing something that even if a guy can't
do is pretty special
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]